nyx warsaw is here did i get it right
yep sure
and do you want a writer i'm already so
fucking giggly could you be wearing more
bracelets that are gonna make more noise
i mean could you be could you be more of
a sound problem i mean
what did you do that they have a sale at
claire's what's happening
i shop at forever 45
[Laughter]
i shop at never 45
yeah because i'm going to kill myself
before then
no some of these are uh gifts and um
shaman
your floridian shaman gave you
a kiosk in fort lauderdale yeah i got
this from the mayor of key west
they are retiring my arms
um no it's a group called four ocean
these are made out of like recyclable
plastics and uh i'm big into like
helping environment oh really yeah yeah
seriously yeah ocean's a great group
like they pick up trash and
like tons and tons of trash and stuff
and help clean it up yeah they don't
spend a ton of time on designing the
merch we know that we know where they
put their efforts no they're blind
yeah that's one thing i should have said
they are like we need to clean up the
trash by putting it around people
yeah sometimes they'll just go and
realize that they're just in an alley
picking up trash it's like no the
ocean's that way i do
that's a coke can in a puddle of urine
hold on i
thought
i think last night i had a really good
idea of how to save the world i mean
like the environment all right this is
real debatable no it's a good idea so i
was unwrapping shit yesterday
bubble wrap has got to go
and here's here's what i think should
happen
if you're buying something that needs
bubble wrap you have to go get it in
person like a robot yeah which yes yes
no she's not even bubble wrap that was
uh mush you can use like old blankets
and old stuff you're gonna throw away
but bubble wrap should go and then if
you want something that's fragile you
have to buy it in person and that's just
a new law
okay isn't that a kind of a good idea
you'd never own anything huh you'd never
own anything that's not true and now
that i've bought something you get
delivered is like an old glass i know
but
but now that i have it all we can put
the law in place yeah a lot of people
don't notice but if you walk around
whitney's home she broke into a mayan
temple
and stole a bunch of pottery
that would would break if you farted on
it
literally so
yes
this looks like the house of the person
that invented dream catchers
yeah i still look like the house
if you saw the house she'll do a tour of
it
um
you okay i wanted i really i have a lot
to discuss with you uh first of all i am
giggly as shit because do you have in
your head like the top funniest things
you've ever heard like or like in your
mind you're like that's the hardest i've
ever laughed or that like that's the
second hardest i've ever learned there's
a lot of them though like when i if i
like remember a story and i'm talking to
somebody and it's in a context i'll be
like okay this is the one this is the
funniest thing i've ever seen i'll tell
it but i have like a lot of them that
brings up a new year's thing that i did
me and uh my friend graham elwood i love
graham so uh we were at a party
at uh dave rath's house in the valley
yeah this is years ago
and we just decided to ruin everyone's
new year
and so at 11 30
we started going
five
four and everybody would be like oh
and we kept doing it every five minutes
to the point where when the real
countdown happened
nobody enjoyed it at all it wasn't fun
we had done it like 10 times or whatever
so it was like five
four
whatever
you okay so we did this thing the other
day we were like shooting something
was it a bit or a skit
it was a sketch a skit i think i don't
know he fucking hired i think it was a
bit
whatever it was it was like this kind of
just like random money gig right
and uh and i don't know where anything
goes anymore it was like for netflix i
didn't know if it was an ad or if it's a
show like i don't even know what it is
anymore i'm just like i didn't know i'm
glad i did it
i don't even know when
katya from drag race shows up and i was
like
i'm sorry like we're just not really
sure exactly what this is she goes
that's clear
that's hilarious
that's that's clear
we were just like doing this thing we're
like fucking around and improvising and
that so the day before my face was
really swollen because i did like a
laser and i should have done it fucking
the day after but i did it before like
an idiot and uh
like an idiot and i was like whatever
this thing is like a nothing thing and
then i show up and they're like this is
gonna go on netflix before all the
movies and i was like fuck
and i just looked i was like so swollen
and i could hardly even move my face it
was so sore and then so we're just like
improvising and fucking around and
swords and just goes
why are you wearing a halloween mask
i'm literally still i cannot stop
laughing because your word choice like
there's no such thing as a halloween
there's a freddy krueger mask right
there is
like from the 40s where they just had
just general masks there was only three
masks
before specific masks they were just
like for creativity just scary ones
yeah
that's what that's what i saw and i
could not stop laughing for the rest of
the time yeah
well speaking of like random things that
you remember
i always remember when comedians
get into it with the audience like if
they like the
case in point um
uh this guy alan havey oh yes funny
comedian and he was on stage at the
comedy cellar in new york
and like the set was like going okay but
you could just tell he was just not
feeling it i know these two loud like
really effeminate guys in the front row
that were just being loud annoying
and he goes
let me guess you guys are gay
and uh they're like yeah we are
yeah
and he goes when did you know you were
gay and the guy goes
when i was nine
and he goes when you were nine years old
you were just coloring and decided to
shove the crayon up your asshole
and i
was in the back of the room
fucking lost it
still to this day whenever i see allen i
always bring that up and this is like 15
i love what happens when comedians
are kind of like
like hate fucking their set
and it doesn't matter like it doesn't
count for like i feel like those days
are going away because everyone's like
i've got to shoot this for my instagram
like everyone's shooting a special every
night oh it's the worst everyone comes
in with their camera equipment now and
their tripod and like full hair and
makeup and i'm like what is happening
the days where you just were fucking
around and weren't worried about like
you know everything being uh
uploaded every fucking second like no
one will ever have seen those moments
now
and it's like like
that that will come on to another
subject that i wanted to talk about okay
i'll write it um but also mark maron you
weren't when mark maron and dove dub
davidoff got in a fight at the comedy
store
i get into it but like i've never seen i
mean i've done it on over 25 years now i
mean i've i've never seen comedians like
fist fight
what dude i mean steve byrne someone
came on stage at him once it was like
brett ernst and steve byrne in the or
and someone in the audience you know
like came
out well yeah i'm
[Laughter]
i've known mark forever since i started
and i did this podcast back in the day
when i first was starting up and he goes
um
yeah thanks for doing this song
[Laughter]
you know i've always hated you
and i go
what what are you talking about and he
goes yeah yeah
i uh yeah i always hated you and i go
i've known you for fucking like almost
25 i thought we were friends this whole
time he goes no we are we are but i just
got
yeah i just fucking hated you you know
you were you were young and you were
funny
and you just came in so hot it was heat
and i was like fuck this guy man fuck
him and i was like
for decades you thought that every time
you saw me
every time i said hi to you and like
hugged you or like
you just were thinking man fuck this
fucking guy
i'm like
can comedians be more psycho
fucking lunatic
i know i have a first time and mark i
feel like he's in a very good place now
well that podcast helped a lot you know
yeah yeah well for sure he was able to
just rant he also was was like doing
what he was doing at the time where like
ray romano and seinfeld and all these
like sunny people that were like making
jokes about like answering machines and
uh they would hand you a mean they'd be
like develop a sitcom around you here's
five million dollars yeah it was just
insane i mean i wasn't a part of that
era you know but like whitney was but uh
yeah so then there was an era of comics
that missed that like all this money and
sitcoms and i always felt like mark he
got like development deals and stuff but
if you weren't like network friendly
well that's what the point i was getting
into before you interrupted okay well
can you this no i'm talking fast
i mean i'm not a fucking adderall
fucking mannequin over here good god
okay dakota jesus
fucking mannequin in a haunted house
jesus lord in heaven
pray for me
but i get out of this
fucking adobe alive wherever i am
anyway i don't even remember what i was
talking about oh yeah mark was one of
those guys it's like he always felt like
i don't have a fucking sitcom
[Laughter]
i'm like yeah mark nbc prime time you
kind of show like all right we've got
this wall seinfeld and then you know
friends and then the new show by marc
maron hey fuck you man like that can't
be a show mark
so i think that's what happened
and now he's fine
anyway we'll be right back
we'll be right back
oh god why aren't you doing a podcast
i know i might too it's so fucking
bratty like you're such a brat i am to
not have a bag to be able to just like
sit in your home or to be able to sit on
the beach in key west where you
live in a sand castle yeah so
i just was uh quarantined like everybody
in 2020 and i had all my shows get
cancelled
and uh i'd forgotten i booked a trip to
key west
in december before everything the shit
at the fan
so
you know everything shit it's a fan
kovit and fucking murder hornets and
all this shit so i quarantined in
minnesota where i'm from and this like
basement apartment of the house i bought
my sister
and uh yeah i'm saying that because i
hope she's gonna watch this and want her
to know that i love your sister she's a
fucking lunatic we text like a lot she's
a crazy person
but anyway so i'm just sitting there and
um i hadn't drank for like nine months
and i was like didn't quarantine i just
like
caught up on netflix shows and read and
stuff like that and wrote jokes did
podcasts and um just uh expedia hits me
up i'm like are you ready for your trip
to key west totally forgot about it and
i'm like
oh fuck
so the resort i booked at i called them
and i go hey are you guys open and
they're like no
we open on june 2nd my flight landed on
june 3rd
so i was like oh so you'll be open june
3rd and they're like yeah i'm like okay
get me the fuck out of minnesota because
i just was like didn't want to be in a
basement anymore
so i got a plane went to key west i was
supposed to be there for 10 days
i stayed there for a year and a half
not a joke by the way a fucking year and
a half
where people thought i was dead
i just was like yes i got away from
everything i was just needed a break i
have a text chain with like rogan
santino just about like heard from nick
where's nick like we many times we're
like we lost we lost another great
another one like it's just and then you
would just like text out of nowhere like
hey dyke and it was like he's up he's
back
is this a week in a bernie situation i'm
like we see him being drug around
there's reports of him his body being
drug around on the sand and yeah it was
insane it was so awesome and what is key
west specifically like here i'm actually
and benton can um uh corroborate this
[Laughter]
i didn't see you
because
because you saw me do this in florida we
were in florida last weekend
we had
the time of our lives oh yeah and i was
literally like why are people so fucking
shitty about florida what are like and
then i realized that i think there's a
scam going which is that i think florida
is so dope that it plants these stories
about how crazy the people are so people
don't come there
i love it when i have florida shows
those are my favorite shows
all this like florida man like for crazy
people that see shit in their toast i
feel like they want those rumors to be
out so that nobody comes there right
like how iceland is greenland and
greenland is iceland i mean to be fair
when we were in florida we also started
going a little crazy i mean you were on
roller coasters being like this changed
my life we went to universal studios
yeah dude i'm not a roller coaster
person
orlando
and i believe that roller coasters
should be prescribed for depression by
therapists i looked at whitney and she
was holding the handlebars like this
and i went whitney and she went this is
incredible it was incredible
dude the adrenaline because he's like
they got good now it's the ones that we
were on were all fucking rickety and
shitty yeah well they were made of
wood that's already a red flag they were
always like wet and just like
trash and gross it they figured it out
it's like being in fucking singapore or
some shit like you're innocent you just
get on and boom and then it holds you
like this i mean it changed your
hippocampus you were like looking at
sunsets and i was like we're skipping
eating caramel apples i ate a caramel
apple
like i was like levitating and there was
and i was like there's a drag there was
a dragon at harry potter world that like
came down and like in like talking
looking in the pet store of a harry
potter world if they were real animals
the dragon was the only thing that
screamed when it saw you
everybody else is like a dragon dragon's
like what the fuck is that
whitney's
like what
i hope this caramel apple doesn't melt
my botox
that's the one thing i'm that the
dermatologist said you can't eat no
caramel apples she's like no you're made
out of caramel i wasn't going to tell
you but that's what it is
you are a caramel apple
oh my god dude i love roller coasters
that should be our only mode of travel
there's no
there shouldn't be freeways you just get
on a roller coaster and you're fucking
there dude that would solve like every
problem with depression anxiety yeah
just on your way to work
have you been to six flags magic
mountain no oh my god is it awesome holy
shit yeah that's insanity really oh they
have roller coasters where it's
it's another level there's one where you
start sitting like this
and then it just goes
and now you're facing directly down no
no yeah so it's like you're flying and
my buddy next to me was having such a
panic attack which made me so happy
because i was like i i mean i've i've
done so many roller coasters and my body
hasn't so he was like wait wait wait
wait what
why are we looking down and i'm like
i don't fucking know so i just went
along with it i'm like i don't know but
like it just takes god if you can slip
out of this thing you know i mean i just
fed it
that roller coaster is amazing but one
of my favorite moments was uh me and my
buddy went to six flags he got a roller
coaster
and uh my buddy's a big dude
and uh there's a couple that was um next
to us
and uh
there was a guy or sorry they were
behind us and there was a guy that was
his exact same size
and so there we all get like harnessed
in
and the guy who works the roller coaster
comes over to the guy behind us that was
the same size as my buddy
and he goes hey uh sorry to the guy he
goes hey man you're too big for that
ride that harness isn't gonna it's not
gonna work you're too big for the ride
i'm really sorry and the guy's like oh
really he's like yeah and they like let
him out and my buddy again the same size
maybe even bigger he just goes
what about me
and then the guy was walking away and he
goes
what about me
[Laughter]
he's screaming it and then
it starts taking off and he's like pale
paralyzing fear
and i
sobbing laughing i'm like oh my god
you're gonna fucking fall out this is
gonna break
and he was like
the whole time it just it was awesome it
brought me so much joy and then he was
like i'm not doing this anymore
i haven't been in the universal studios
l.a but should we go i love that one too
that one's not bad because it's good
it's orlando but i want to do the new
ride this up the mummy ride which is
awesome i'm star and that's what we
started yeah oh yeah yeah
face based on me
and we shoot in my house
oh yeah i can shoot it here why do you
think i have those money
i remember you were on
fucking tinder looking at people
you're like i want somebody that looks
like my old boyfriend tootin common
it's a random reference
hi hold on before we talk about key west
because i need to understand because now
i'm now obsessed with florida and we
have a tropical state we have a
caribbean state in the in america and
we've we've decided that it's a trash
place of fuck like backwards fucktards
yeah like it's so crazy
because here's the thing with iceland
and greenland the people that found
iceland it was so beautiful and green
green that they named it iceland so
people wouldn't come there and then
greenland is all icy and bullshit and
they called that greenland so more
people go there so i think that's like
what people do in florida they're like
yeah we're crazy like we don't count our
chats like we're just you don't want to
live here and that's how it stays like
really i that's my i don't know about
that it's my crazy thing yeah so just
everybody was in on that they don't call
me hoe rogan for nothing
who calls you that
mostly her
yeah no ron punches
yeah
that is a good one yeah florida i
like i said i love florida
and uh one of the last shows i did i did
like six shows at in tampa stink already
and it was a blast
dude the crowds are so except miami
miami turns up a little too hard the
shows start at like 10. one of my
favorite shows i did uh this was like
two tours ago it was in orlando
and i walk into the venue
and um
i was like
this uh what is this
some backstage and they have big big
murals of like the lion king
fan of the opera
and all these
shows
and they go oh yeah this is a
performance art center and i'm like
it's what they're like it's performance
art center i'm like do you guys get a
lot of comedy and they're like yeah we
have comedians and i'm like
do you guys have security
and they're like
i mean we have ushers
i'm like
how old are they
and they're like you know they're
volunteers and it's like old like ladies
and stuff they're used to doing the lion
king
and i was like thinking about like my
shows and my fans who are the best by
the way you know you are
so i go
here's the deal
you're gonna need to just be ready
and they're like what do you mean i'm
like my fans will come in hot
and they're like he's like oh okay no i
feel like sweating because they're on
cocaine they're literally overheating
and having strokes he's like no we'll be
fine we'll be fine we'll be fine so do
the show
break up a fist fight in the balcony two
chicks
fight your shows are like spirit
airlines oh it's amazing yeah totally
100 no spirit airlines
so they fucking go nuts and then um
three people kicked out
and uh i do my shows awesome crowd was
great i get off stage and the guy was
like yeah yeah that was um
yeah we weren't ready for that and i go
i told you man and he goes
uh yeah we found
three people sleeping in the bathroom
and there's vomit all over both
bathrooms men and women's
and i'm like
yeah
i'm not yep that's what i said we now
take a break from uh the effervescent
nick swordstown this interview i am
dying laughing the entire time like i am
he i'm like giddy i know you guys
probably think i'm high but i swear he
nick just is that funny to me um
i'm not putting my hair in a very
oh like a who oh i look like a who
shit
um
is that every time i say uh my name is
whitney cummings people go who
um
here is a cringe-worthy start to 2022.
yes uh each year 35 of the food supply
goes unsold or uneaten in the u.s but
imperfect foods is working to turn this
around by sourcing foods that would
otherwise fall through the cracks of our
food system and perfect foods is a
grocery delivery service offering an
entire line of sustainable groceries
that taste delicious and reduce waste
just by embracing the natural
imperfections in food so on average
imperfect foods customers they save six
to eight pounds of food with every order
and unlike on-demand delivery companies
imperfect delivers weekly like by
neighborhood it's a unique model did you
did you see me just try to pretend like
i was coming up with it that was like i
like no it was it was great like they
know i'm reading i'd hire you they know
i'm reading this but i just tried to go
like it's um it's like this unique model
that produces like
25 to 75 i'm just gonna spit ball the
exact number they wrote down for me as
if i know it
so well that i'm now explaining it to
you idiots
like
why did i just try to pretend like i was
just coming up with this on the spot
that was that was like elizabeth holmes
shit right there that was a con artist
that was a con artist move i i am
reading this you guys
right now imperfect foods is offering
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfectfoods.com and
use promo code whitney again 20 off your
first order um
first four orders holy shit wow see i
need to eat more food i need more fruit
because perfect or not my brain is
my brain isn't perfect
again 20 of your first four orders
that's up to an 80
value at imperfectfoods.com offer code
when you use promo code whitney join the
movement at imperfectfoods.com
and use code whitney this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and hosted by
people who need it and use it
better
better health will assess your needs and
match you with your own personal
licensed professional therapists now
that betty white is dead we all need
better health they should have yeah this
should be a big year that was that was
traumatic i would like to do a group uh
grieving counseling session on better
health so better help is is truly a
miracle if better help had been around
when i was in my 20s i probably wouldn't
be a stand-up comedian that's so true
and i wouldn't have a job
and so um there is a broad range of
expertise available i think the hardest
part about any kind of therapy is
finding the right therapist right they
match you to the right therapist it's
more affordable than regular counseling
and you get to do it in your own home
yep financial aid is available amazing
take it away anything else special offer
for good free listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com whitney
speaking of mental illness this weekend
i will be in san diego at the balboa
theater um jason ellis from uh uh tony
hawk and ellis's uh wolf and um hawk and
wolf podcast uh is going to pop in
january 8th uh this
whatever you know what the fuck it is uh
kingsbury hall january 28th i'm coming
to nashville polk theater that is gonna
be a blast i am gonna add some special
guests to a bunch of the shows so go to
whitneycomings.com do not go to
whitneycomings.net that will get you on
a list uh back to
nick swartzen and just fyi there might
be
some construction noise later in this
podcast it's a tiny bit know that we
know yes you're not going crazy
there was like a lawnmower or like a
wasn't it's a cement we were cutting
cement with a saw cement
sea man you say cement cement yeah i
don't think cement how do you say pat
it depends on
depends on who pays him
do you say semen or cement i thought
i say come
i never say sea man
please see man for me
yeah put that semen in my mouth did you
say cement or semen cement
can i get some of your cement like what
let's stop trying to make this classy
you say come
emily i say prayers i say ejaculate
back to nick i say it doesn't matter
because none of these sperm are going to
find life in there anyway
it's just
it's just cetaphil at this point
do you listen to podcasts no why not
why i don't know why i why would i
why would i
why would anyone
i don't know i'd rather what to what
just dance
no but there's really good murder uh
murder podcasts and like story podcasts
no i've i've heard some
i'm obviously lying i've heard some i
did i am listening to one with elizabeth
holmes like elizabeth holmes trial and
i'm obsessed with it because it like
totally takes my mind off of like comedy
it's like you know when you're like
watching shit like i can't enjoy tv and
movies as much just because you're like
oh fuck i should have
thought of that or i should you know
what i mean it's like
it's a form of entertainment that i'm
not like i could have done that better i
should have if i'd worked harder i'd
have you know what i mean i don't get
yeah all in my fucking head yeah totally
i know what you're saying and then
what's going on with uh doing another
hour because you are so smart and i
learned this from you to like take
breaks from stand up so that you can
like fucking fuel up and like have a
life and not just like well i was ready
for an hour and then uh
covet hit like right it was just the
worst timing i was all ready and i had a
tv show and
i had all this stuff everything got
fucked and then that just goes back to
like key west and then do you not want
to do any of that material that you have
for that
no i do like i i
like i said i went to key west for a
year and a half
where everybody i was ready to quit
everything i was just so over
just over it what's the vibe like what's
the key west like what's uh it's so
fucking removed it's like what's a city
in l.a it's like oh hi like it's like
nothing else because it's not torture
it's like nothing else it's like you
know when pinocchio goes to the island
with all the bad kids and they start
turning into donkeys because they're
being bad and smoking cigars that's key
west
where
yeah when i got off the plane my buddy
picked me up
oh it's an island but basically yeah i
mean it's one look at the water it's one
long stretch look at the fucking water
that goes to miami those are i mean it's
a famous bridge it's the caribbean
yeah it's awesome but when i landed in
key west my buddy picked me up and he
goes welcome to the island of misfit
toys
and i go what does that mean and he goes
oh you'll see
and i did see for a year and a half and
he goes you're gonna fit in here so well
and i'm like what does that mean and
he's like you'll see so a fucking year
and a half look how beautiful this water
is no it's great
but the locals everybody everybody's so
cool it's just it's it looks like the
maldives
yeah it's nice
don't talk about nobody's on
you know it was just away from hollywood
and bullshit
yeah there was no dolphins people
weren't on twitter the whole time and
all that is that what it looks like
is that a picture of key west
then yes whitney
then yes no that's key west iowa
that's a key part of iowa
it's a secret i didn't know it was the
name of kim kardashian's new kid but
here's the thing it uh it looks like
jamaica
that is so cute
yeah i know jesus christ are you gonna
get a place there i know don't i thought
about it
but now i know i'm back and i'm i'm i'm
gonna get back and stand up is that the
branch
is that the bridge you live under
yeah
that was that was where i stayed
god that is so fucking gorgeous because
it's like i'm i'm fascinated by like
there's so many different floridas in
florida you know like there's so many
different
little
moments like every city is so different
yes
the only thing horrifying about orlando
is the airport
i don't remember because it's all kids
leaving disneyland they're so super
scared
and sad why because they were just like
is that disney world in orlando i don't
know but dude disney i we should go to
dis is it disneyland hong kong or disney
world hong kong that is supposed to be
sick um well okay i wanna know what
you're gonna like what are you gonna
talk about the next question because i
feel like post pandemic a lot of the
shit that i was working on i was like
this is just not a problem anymore
well i mean i'm not going to talk about
covid and bullshit like i want to just
go back to where i was yeah
so i mean there's nothing it's a lot of
stories and you know there's nothing
like jarringly
i'm not going way off topic
if you go to my show it would be like oh
nick's back you know is it crazy to be
back in l.a and have to wear masks
yeah i mean it's i don't know i think i
wear a mask
[Laughter]
by the way so do fucking you why does
your skin look so good this happened the
other day if you've been in key west
this makes no sense i know it's really
bizarre because i was there was a
squalling jeffries did yeah
jim jeffries had a joke and he's like
you know i fucking was an alcoholic
shame smoker drug addict i've done all
these things
and he goes
how do i look this good
and uh people say that to me not like i
look that great but i think you're
embalmed but people
you pickled yourself
they embalm me when i'm sleeping my
agents just
but no i you know for as much as i've i
was never a big drug guy but as much as
i've drank and smoked i shouldn't look
hey dude heroin addicts former heroin
addicts always look fucking amazing
because i think what happens is your
body is in such shock i mean well i
guess the ones in hollywood are actors
i know there's probably other things but
it uh there's something about how it
does you kind of stop aging because your
body is so focused on staying alive and
removing it from the body right it's
like it doesn't have time to stop making
collagen it's just like we'll keep
making collagen that's why i always said
i'm like i'm going to start doing heroin
and when i'm 80.
dude absolutely 100 goals
all of it i would like to i mean
do you think we'll make it to 80
but i'd like to think that i could
like are you gonna be in florida
full-time do you think you're gonna just
move there imagine how much he'd save in
taxes i don't know i mean the taxes
would be great key west is really hard
to get in and out of and so
it's lax is easier uh no
i mean you haven't been to key west i
have seen a couple photos on the
internet at least i think that's what's
on the green apparently like you do
every fucking five seconds
you're like they have a great laugh
factory here
there's two seats because that's how
many people fucking live there
but yeah no key west is it's hard to get
out there's no direct from la to key
west just to give you an example there's
no direct that's why you've never been
yeah exactly i don't do i i took spirit
air i
forced us to take spirits we took spirit
airlines because i would not awful do a
connecting vomit in the back pocket of
my seat it was it was
it was it was
my job and when i showed her she went
don't talk about it my travel my travel
agent and she was like what did she say
our travel agent said
i'm really nervous a lot of people
getting fist fights on this plane
[Applause]
really where were you flying to we were
flying to boston maybe no well i don't
know
milwaukee and uh it was uh so wild
because it's the only airline i've ever
flown that when you're standing in line
other people getting on the plane are
like one gate to each different place
well they're like are you going to
milwaukee like and everyone's like you
go like everyone's checking with each
other because you enter through one door
and then you veer off to different
planes so if you get on the wrong plane
you just have the wrong place they save
money in the walkways i guess and they
use old planes like that's their
business model is they use old planes so
you get on this round yellow what's that
oh and they're yellow and we get on and
it was like well they don't recline they
don't recline yeah which is fucking
insanity
and like how do they save money i guess
like not like putting the button in or
something is how they get the cost down
and me and the fucking uh flight
attendant that's oh we're in a fight we
were in a full fight cause when spirit
airline takes off they tell you to you
have to close all the windows because
they can't have any light coming in or
the pilot can't see they said no no they
may just close all the windows and
whitney wouldn't do it and they kept
going ma'am close your window didn't i
okay you're doing the opposite that's
because you go up you put the thing up
oh got it i'll close your window right
and so i ca i get fucking migraines and
you know that like when you
you keep it down and then you're taking
off and as soon as you're like
moving you can kind of scoot it up right
right ma'am like i mean he was
it went on we had four or five exchanges
yeah you were just staring at each other
and you were holding the window like
waiting to do it
i know he was just staring at me the
entire time and then and then we landed
the same thing happened and then his
announcement i've never heard anyone say
this he goes so when we take off the
engine's gonna be a little loud like
it's all good remember you know
a little loud so just don't worry yeah
we're like what my god
so only like airline where you can pay
in like monopoly money
you can take monopoly money and be like
here's 15
you get miles at chipotle you have a
fighter
we got a gift certificate yeah we got a
50 credit each of us had a credit so
that's why again so that's six flights
because the flight was four hours late
the plane was four hours late and then
the flight attendant never came by he
just sat in that little chair and he was
on tinder the whole time
pendant said uh it's called spirit
airlines because by the time you get
there your spirit
because you're you're you're
you're a spirit by the time you land ben
didn't see shit on planes that i've
never seen
will you yeah i saw a six-year-old woman
in a bdsm relationship
you know what a bdsm relationship what
is that like you know like slave master
how did you know that they were because
her font was huge on her phone and i was
sitting like this so i read all of her
some of it and i shared pictures of it
was in german
good god but she was
breaking up with this man he was
breaking up with her and she was like
please master don't leave me he sent her
sending her videos of him flopping his
penis like this and then he was holding
a cat no i'm sorry he put barbecue
sauce on a vagina
this is now i like that
oh that was delta
it was just she was dressed like this
art teacher from santa fe and it was
like master slave master slave like can
i eat a blueberry she said i'm too shy
to do um double penetration yeah i'm too
shy i don't i mean i don't think that's
the and then he asked her not to speak
to him for two weeks yes but she also
she also uh was asking i love this idea
that she's like may i have a blueberry
and he's like oh yeah he's like you can
only have and then she's like pounding a
cliff bar but she's like may i eat today
and he's like no she also kept calling
her he kept sending her her pictures of
his butt and she kept calling it a boy
pussy
but in german
okay
and then you saw the the name and it was
marc maron
hey fuck you man i heard whitney's
podcast fuck you
he would never he would never allow
himself to listen to my podcast that's
the only i don't think he's ever heard
another one this reminds me of uh an
intro story
about um when i was on tour me adam
sandler rob schneider david spade
and uh we're doing a whole floor-to-leg
and um norm mcdonald was supposed to be
there norma's one of my best best
friends in the world
and uh that was just awful and he was
supposed to be there and um
this is a side story sorry
and uh we land in florida in orlando and
uh we're on a text thread all of us
and we're like norm we're here did you
land yet he's like
uh what
we're like we're in orlando are you here
and he's like
orlando uh
what are you guys doing there
and we're like
we have four fucking shows in florida
and he goes uh i didn't know that
and then uh i go
norm you're on the thread if you scroll
up you say i'll see you in orlando you
said that yesterday yes
oh yeah
ah
shit
and adam's like good god
so he just forgot
anyway the point of the story is the
flight he just didn't get on the flight
that was i don't know it's norm because
i have a billion dorm stories but
so intro so we're at the hotel car picks
us up at six sandler goes early he's
gotta do sound check he's got a guitar
and a whole music thing
so it's me and spade and schneider so me
and david are in the car
at 6 00 p.m like on the night on the
fucking dot
and uh we're waiting on rob so we're on
a text ride and i'm like rob where are
you we're in the car shooting a sitcom
so we're waiting and waiting and now
it's like 6 20 and we're like hey man
what's up and he goes
uh
oh i'm just getting in the shower and i
tell the driver i go go i go fuck this
go he's like you want me to leave rob i
go yeah yeah just leave them david's
like okay
so
we take off leave rob
so we get to the venue stanley goes
where's rob
and uh no i'm sorry he goes
so
we get to the venue adam's like where's
rob i go i go i we left him and then
david goes you left him
and i'm like whatever i'm not fucking
sitting in the car for a fucking half
hour insane
so rob shows up livid and he's on the
thread before that like fuck you david's
like blame nick
she was like fuck you nick i'm gonna
fuck your intro up and i'm like okay
cause rob's hosting the show
so i'm like whatever dude
so we start the show again this is in
orlando florida
so we go
show starts robbed it goes on kayla's
doing great brings me up
great intro he's like ah this next guy
hilarious just go with it grandma's boy
blah blah blah nick schwartzen i'm like
oh that's fine so i go up do my set
and then uh
rob goes back out to bring up spade so
rob does some time and he goes hey uh
before i bring up your next act i know
there was a brutal shooting at the gay
bar pulse
and i was a massacre and i just want to
have a moment of silence i can't believe
it was
six months ago today
that that happened and i just think we
should do a moment of silence some guy
in the crowd goes uh it was a year ago
it was a year ago somebody else goes
yeah that was a year
and he goes
oh and he looks off to the side of the
stage i'm standing next to like a crew
member
and he goes well that fucking guy
he fucking told me six months ago
and i go
and i look at the crew member and he
goes
i've never talked to him in my life
and he goes yeah that fucking crew guy
fucking asshole
hey fuck you man
anyway sorry about that
uh anyway fuck i don't know joe dirt and
then he walks off stage that was david's
intro
a fucking gay massacre moment of silence
that
failed epically
and then just he just says joe dirt and
walks off angry throw
some crew guy
as if that was gonna save it even if he
did but then david was like maddie it's
like
you're the one that left him at the
hotel oh why did i get the gay massacre
moment of silence
wait so he brought
spade up instead by accident no what did
you just miss the whole point of the
fucking story
[Laughter]
do you listen to your own podcast as
it's being taped
you're like you don't listen to podcasts
you don't listen to your fucking own
no
you're in all those same movies and i
thought he was going to fuck up your
intro that's what i would that was the
whole guy
he goes nick i'm going to fuck up your
intro but then he goes and fucks over
david oh god and david wasn't the one
that left them at the time it's
confusing because you're in all those
movies too
because you guys are a fucking package
deal will you uh really quick um
oh norm story that this is in my top
like 10 things that are funny he uh
we're in the roseanne writer's room
right in which i'd never worked with
norm in a writer's room capacity before
and he came in one day a week
one day just needed one day show runner
bruce helford ran his sitcom and a lot
of his writers from bruce rasmussen a
bunch of people that were on a sitcom
i'm like what's it like working with
norm like in writer's room and he's like
it's it's kind of like trying to give a
cat a bath
and then so norm would come in one day a
week and he'd be in the room for like
maybe like 20 minutes
over like five hours but he always had
the funniest it didn't matter you know
but contributed more than people that
were there five days a week right right
and
he like had pitched some joke and then
there's this writer in the room that's
amazing she's like a showrunner and but
everything has to what the fuck is that
we're getting the light um uh uh and
this she's like well i just don't
understand this joke like what does it
mean for their relationship you know
because it was literally like darlene
calling becky whore or something and
she's like what does it mean because
like in the next episode we need to
build towards their emotional you know
and she's like so just
why
why would we put that in and he just
goes uh because
comedy
that's awesome it was just like the
meanest like
like it was it was like bad
because that's great comedy that's i can
totally see and then he just left he was
just like because uh comedy yeah it was
just like so fucking simple such a
savage okay well now
that um
my house is being rebuilt underneath us
i will release you yeah they're building
a robot army
no they're working on my new face
downstairs
this one this is your animatronic hat
this isn't your
real face right
we now take a break you know
talking to nick schwartzen for this long
like
i don't know you know everyone has that
friend in their life where you're like
look if we haven't found someone yes yes
by 45 yeah let's just have a kid
together yeah
me and nick so having a kid yeah people
like us you can't just throw that around
and assume it's going to happen
fertility you got to take fertility into
account right here's the thing though
until now it's not been an easy thing
when i got my fertility checked like
eight years ago when i froze my eggs i
had to go into a place i had to wait for
two hours
and then they were like man this is a
dmv please go to a doctor's office man
put your pants on
modern fertility is an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a single
finger brick you mail it to a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within 10 days traditional
testing with your doctor can cost over a
thousand dollars but modern fertility
which will make you infertile writing
that check your whole body shuts down
but also if you don't like spending
money you should not want to be fertile
kids
yeah i know but it's also it's like i
needed that thousand dollars to pay for
the kids you know college pox uh modern
fertility gets you the same information
at 159 dollars that's what a child
should cost
a fraction of the price you have money
left over for therapy yeah and if you go
to modernfertility.com
whitney you can get 20
off your test also if you have an hsa or
fsa you can put those dollars toward
modern fertility right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to modern
fertility.com
whitney that means your test will cost
139 instead of several hundred not to
mention the hours of time and stress and
putting on that embarrassing gown and
having that like cold roll your
underwear and put it in yeah and having
the the fertility guy kiss you because
that's part of the test
yeah and like you squeeze your boobs
it's just like i don't right you know
what i mean he's like the only way to
really check if you're fertile is for me
to pregnant you and then oh my god no i
need to get in my house before my wife
gets home
so
your test is 139 instead of several
hundred or even a thousand plus dollars
it could cost at a doctor's office get
twenty dollars off your fertility test
when you go to modern
modernfertility.com
whitney
modern fertility.com
so
if you did
go to the fake fertility guy
let's say you went to a sketchy doctor
and got the tetanus you know
how are you gonna take care of yourself
how are you gonna uh replenish your
hydrate rehydrate yeah vitamin yourself
there's a new company called liquid iv
but before i say everyone's new year's
resolutions right is always to get
healthier right one stick of liquid iv
in 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water
alone i knew water was full of shit they
have flavors watermelon because
water is gross it tastes like spit it
does taste like cement and they have
water melon lemon lime strawberry pina
colada what and more one stick of liquid
iv in 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone
liquid iv five essential vitamins b3 b5
b6 b12 vitamin c
with three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks made with
premium ingredients non-gmo and free
from gluten dairy and soy what i love
the most about liquid iv is that i just
i hate water and this makes water more
fun grab liquid iv in bulk or nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidity.com and use code whitney
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you use promo code whitney at
liquidity.com experience better
hydration today at liquidity.com promo
code whitney liquid iv get it back to
nick schwartzen and just a heads up
again there might be a little bit of
background noise for about 30 seconds i
didn't want to cut the story because it
was such a funny mcdonald's story so we
didn't cut it but you're gonna hear some
noise kept it on purpose you're not
catching a mistake i know we got it we
got it okay i thought it was just my
inner monologue but everyone heard it
i want to talk about cameo also
oh yeah i'm back on cameo dude i had a
blast doing it a couple years ago and it
was really fun dude cameo is the most
fun dude and people like it's an app on
your iphone that you basically can pay
to have your favorite celebrity make a
personalized message for you
it it's not it's not hard for us to do
like a lot of people like i wouldn't
want to it's like it's so much fun it's
like i was doing crowd work or something
yeah i love doing it and like i can do
characters i'm like yeah if you want me
to do terry for me or not one or just go
with it like dolph the dolph or whatever
like
i mean i like really personalized it's
just fun to do and people are like and
they really love it but you always have
that so when you go to like a show or
see me live or something you know you
don't you don't get that and you don't
get a personalized video forever of me
you know wishing
you know whatever you buy because that's
when you play graduation yeah if you're
looking to meet and greet and you're
like paying money to meet somebody
you're gonna just get a photo and that's
it and when i see them because when i s
a friend like friends of mine that have
gotten them from other celebrities which
i think is funny i want to do that for
christmas do it just from all my friends
like get you one from sagitt like get it
i
those people that i would love to get a
video from that i don't know but
watching them do it is also so funny
because it is like kind of awkward you
know but that's what's like it's like
feels even more personal because it's
kind of this intimate moment and so a
friend of mine cindy she got one from uh
uh just incredible the magician justin
wilman i guess now and i watched and i
felt weird being like can i see it
because he's a friend of mine and i want
to find him i want to like clown on him
and be like here and he was like having
such a good time he's like hey
like he was like that's so much more fun
than performing at this point because
it's like you know someone's getting it
you're making their day and they get to
have it forever yeah and you get like
responses too and you get to do it on
your terms it's like not like i have to
do the show tonight at 8 o'clock it's
like i can do it in the morning i can do
what i have time
i really want to get on there and start
doing it
yeah it's a blast but i love the the
requests that i get because i had to go
like hey man you know i'm on cameo uh
you know if you want a video if you want
to do a character whatever but i'm like
just you know have it be logical or not
logical but like normal
like i'm not gonna you know sometimes
people be like hey what's up man big fan
can you tell my mom to suck my dog's
dick and i'm like
no i'm not gonna do that like you gotta
even though that makes me laugh
but i can't say that on camera and tell
somebody to fucking do that
i like that like what are the main
requests you get benton um i just get a
lot of like can you tell me about icon
legend star can you tell my mom happy
birthday my sister's a lesbian when you
tell her that's okay yeah i get that
like can you i hit a lot of my cameos
when i was getting my lipo i was just
doing them
with that thing on your head
i think they should get a refund
personally
[Laughter]
um what's the weirdest cameo request
you've got besides that one
it gets weirder than that i don't know
people aren't that deranged
no that was like one of the weirdest
um no they're all just kind of in the
same ballpark there was nothing like
you know nothing that insane you have to
get on community too
it's where you somebody shows cancel no
i don't know i guess i could bring it
back
can you reboot community
no
[Laughter]
it's an app where someone can text you
like all your fans can text you it's
kind of like a mailing list but you can
respond to them and like send like like
daily birthday messages and stuff and
then they put in their cities so that
when you go to their city
you can just so here's all the people so
i've got like 40 000 or something of
people all over the world right and then
if i'm going to orlando i can find just
the one in orlando and send them a text
orlando florida so these right i'll say
here
that vicinity of people
can you not afford a hotel
oh my god no it's to promote shows
hey guys two of a place i could
guys have food or oil for a robot
[Laughter]
just cameo but for free
no and then you and then you send it to
2 000 people in toledo and then only
they get like the
updates for the show so you're not
blasting your instagram with a bunch of
shit about toledo that most people don't
live there right okay and it goes
directly to them right so most people
change their email all the time or don't
check their email or like mailing lists
on email are kind of like spam this goes
right to their
awesome yeah another thing that i won't
figure out how to use
yeah you when or just as we sign off
here where can people find you instagram
or no
i'm not back on instagram yet it's
because you don't have your password i
just i got locked out no no you didn't i
didn't so i go i want to reset my
password you didn't get locked out i
said i want to reset my password and
they were like okay what's your username
and it's real nick schwartzen okay i
really like schwartzen and they're like
we don't recognize that person that
person died in key west months ago
um yeah my spirit is there no but we but
you have the email that it's under
that's all you need right
it's a username on instagram not email i
don't think yeah
i don't know i'll figure it out i'll
i'll be back but who i mean who did you
ask about i mean what skyler stone like
who's giving you this advice
nobody gets that reference i know it's
just for you um no i just tried to use
the app
like a fucking human oh so but you said
they i'm sorry i was a non-binary i was
just trying to use some correct pronouns
whatever the fuck wherever the fuck
works there
[Laughter]
i'll get you with someone hold on
no i'll figure it out it's not like no
you won't the way you're talking i don't
think you will
um okay i love you
cameo you're going to be touring at some
points i'll be back i'll yeah i'll be
back at some point um
not
i'm doing uh uh i had a movie come out
during covet too the wrong mission on
netflix was spade okay
don't watch it you've already watched it
it's already been number one and then
the buddy games my whole point being
buddy
games went number one and we got a
sequel paramount picked it up and we're
doing a sequel this april don't don't
support it he's too successful and it's
not it's it's it makes me jeff
i fucking i've always hated you
that would be great stop making me happy
everybody should say that when i get
motherfuckers i've always hated you i
told olivia mine came on before we were
like friends she came on and i just
couldn't help ed and i was like i have
been so jealous of you for so long she's
also in buddy games oh yeah and she was
like
okay cool and i was like no like i
you've been in my psyche like you
have like you know like i don't know
maybe this just a girl thing or just a
me thing and scary thing whereas like
when you're coming up there like there's
one person that you think is your cum
the fact that i thought she was my
competition is also hilarious uh but uh
that i was like yeah it's always her me
but it kind of was for a while because
she was like booking all these sitcoms
she was getting all these parts like and
she was on g4 like she just like i
auditioned for everything that she got
you know right and then so i was just
like
in my head she was just like someone
that i kind of i guess i didn't hate but
i was just jealous of that annoyed me
you know right that i was like
and i told her and she was like cool i
feel like people
say that to her a lot i thought i was
like i know i thought it was the first
person to ever be like admit that i was
jealous you were she said you were yeah
she was just like
i was like weren't you jealous of me too
i'm gonna tell olivia to start a podcast
now
i think she's going to a mommy one oh
really i'm going to be olivia's manager
yeah
oh no she asked me to be her manager
last valentine's day and i might take
her out i know she took my idea i'm
gonna hit her up
okay i love you love you too thanks for
having me uh if you want you have to
start a podcast dude it's we it's weird
um yeah i know i've i've always thought
about it so maybe i won't it would in
the amount of time you think about it
you could have just done it like it's
that it's that easy for you right
i'm doing it in key west
like truly why not
yeah just bring on why do you hate money
boom you don't but you don't have to
have guests like bill burr just like
half of burr's podcast is him trying to
plug in his computer
and it is i love bill it is he's just
like where's the fucking plug he's like
god damn it it's so funny it's just him
trying to figure out like he can't read
the ads he's like man escaped i think a
man escaped is escaped or escaped like
he's just can't even read the ads like
he just yells at the sponsors he's like
this is the stupidest fucking copy i've
ever seen i'm not reading this we were
both big sports fans and like back in
the day when he started his podcast he's
like will you come on and do it is that
cool and i'm like yeah of course
so i went on and he's like i just need
like half hour and i'm like okay i'm
gonna talk sports and i was i was on for
so long
it was like an hour 45. it was like
really long but it was great because
he's so easy to talk to and you know
sports and and there's just like nothing
he's so funny won't be pissed about and
still think about it the pumpkin patch
the the the horrors of the pumpkin patch
because it's all influencers taking pic
like slutty pictures of pumpkins and
he's like my kids are there and some
girl is just like spread eagle on a
fucking hay bale for her instagram like
it's turned into fucking porn convention
oh god yeah i always say he's one of my
favorite comics unlike you i don't get
jealous of people and
have a complete breakdown i've always
hated you i know you can't see that i'm
jealous because my face the good thing
is you can't tell any expressions i had
um
okay all right we end these awkwardly i
love you go to your lunch cameo cameo
cameo
real nick schwartz on instagram i'll be
back we're gonna get him back on
instagram he will be back on instagram
soon
um uh i love you guys don't write
elephants goodbye
[Music]
one